[Music]
on this saturday night the battle for
kiev
fierce fighting around the capitol the
explosions are in every district of kiev
it's like a nightmare ukrainians dig
deep to defend their country and plead
for the world to hell you need to act
now to stop russian aggression global
condemnation we hate what's just
happening right now in our country
stepping up the pressure on vladimir
putin to end the invasion also tonight
lifting restrictions we can say with
confidence that the numbers continue to
decline rapidly alberta moves closer to
post-pandemic life and climate diplomacy
the push for an international treaty to
fight plastic pollution
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
sophie louie
[Music]
explosions lighting up the night sky
around kiev tonight as the russian
military makes a push to close in on the
ukrainian capital ukraine's military and
civilian volunteers have so far managed
to hold off the russian advancement
but as darkness has fallen the assault
has escalated tonight terrified men
women and children sheltered inside and
underground in kiev many are taking
refuge in the city's subway stations
tens of thousands of ukrainians have
already fled the country
ukrainian president vladimir zolensky in
a new video earlier today maintaining
his resolve and his position in kiev
good evening and thanks for joining us
european leaders along with canada and
the u.s are now stepping up economic
pressure and blocking selected russian
banks from accessing the swift financial
messaging system which facilitates
cross-border payments that's in response
to russia's ongoing assault on ukraine
the ukrainian government says at least
200 people have been killed on its soil
more than 1500 civilians have been hurt
including 34 children our crystal
commencing is in poland tonight about an
hour's drive from the ukrainian border
and joins us now crystal
sophie ukraine's president wants peace
as members of his team told me he wants
it through negotiations not death
vladimir zelensky says he is willing to
engage with vladimir putin even on the
issue of ukraine's neutrality but he is
not willing to bow to any kremlin
ultimatums
from night
to day
at all hours the sounds of war echo
through the streets of king
it's like a nightmare but the most
outrageous is that it isn't
a nightmare it isn't a dream
it's our reality olha faisiva is in the
capital when her husband and brother
signed up to serve she moved in with her
parents
there is a bomb shelter a three-minute
walk away but it's full so they sit in
the dark together waiting
no we are not safe it's impossible to be
you know safe when you open the window
and you can hear the explosions no okay
not near your house your apartments but
you can hear them
you never know
what
direction
will be on the next time
ukrainians are resisting the world's
second most powerful army using every
possible method a video shared widely
from buckmuch in the country's north
shows a man standing in front of a
russian tank
he then kneels down
an act of peaceful defiance that is
being compared to a similar scene from
tiananmen square in
1989 those who could make their way out
of the country after russia launched its
full-scale invasion have fled to
neighboring countries such as moldova
and poland to seek shelter las
we were taken vegas car and then we
walked for a long time because it was
impossible to go we walked for almost
half of the night to the border crossing
point the polish government says the
country has already taken in more than
100 000 people in the past 48 hours
many more will come if the fighting
continues
[Music]
i do not know if it will be possible to
see my relatives my friends or return to
ukraine
it is very difficult to talk about and
that is something we are hearing from so
many people as they cross over into
poland and safe territory they are
desperately afraid about what happens to
those they've left behind in ukraine
they are also calling for the world to
act and force russia to end this war
sophie
crystal command sing in poland crystal
thank you now amid the siege on the
ukraine capital an impassioned plea for
help from vladimir klitschko the brother
of kiev's mayor a former boxing
heavyweight champion who enlisted in
ukraine's reserve army earlier this
month
you need to act now to stop
russian aggression
with anything you can have
now
in an hour
or by tomorrow it's going to be too late
residents of kiev remain under a curfew
as battles continue between ukrainian
and russian forces joe fetterman is a
journalist with the associated press on
the ground in kiev i spoke with him
earlier about the curfew and president
zelinski's defiance in the face of
russia's aggression
kiev's mayor extended that overnight
curfew until monday morning
in order to prevent residents from being
mistaken for russian saboteurs what does
he mean by saboteurs
yes they believe that uh there are
elements within ukraine's own population
who are sympathetic to the russian cause
if you remember ukraine was part of the
soviet union has a long history uh with
russia it has its own russian-speaking
uh minority and they believe that there
are people within the population who are
assisting uh the russian forces so
they're trying to use this time now it's
about 36 hours of complete closure uh to
track down and when they say that some
of these units actually disguise
themselves they wear ukrainian uniforms
and so forth so they're using this
coming period 36 hours to track down
these uh so-called
saboteurs
all right president zielenski has
appeared in another video
to show that he remains in kiev despite
the russian advances he also turned down
a u.s offer to evacuate and according to
ukraine's embassy in london zalenski
said the fight is here i need ammunition
not a ride
how long can president zielenski hold
out do you think
yeah that's a question um i can't give
you an answer i can't predict the future
what i can tell you is if you would ask
me this yesterday i would have given you
a different answer yesterday it felt
like the russian army was just closing
in on the city and it was a matter of
time before everything collapsed today
it feels like the tide has turned a bit
it seems that the ukrainian military is
putting up quite the fight putting up
some stiff resistance that's why it's so
quiet in the city uh and uh zielinski i
think is one of the reasons for this uh
he has remained in the city he has
resisted uh calls to flee he's making
videos in his office he's sticking with
his people and i thinking that's i think
that's helping uh motivate uh his forces
how long they can continue this it's
impossible to say but the uh the
performance of the ukrainian military i
think is a lot stronger than what people
had thought uh it might have been and
president zielenski uh setting quite an
example for his people all right thanks
for that associated press reporter joe
fetterman joining us once again
canada's ambassador to the united
nations bob ray calls the attack on
ukraine a grotesque war crime saying
what is happening is brutal thuggery
unprovoked evil and aggression but
beyond stern words for russia what
exactly can the united nations do about
what's unfolding in ukraine mercedes
stevenson interviews him on the west
block here's a preview
you've dealt a tremendous amount in your
career with human rights you were
looking at war crimes you were tweeting
about this can you tell us a little bit
about what your concerns are in
particular on war crimes in ukraine
right now being committed by russia i
saw you tweeting about thermobaric
weapons uh concerns that those could
potentially be used in the conflict what
are we seeing so far and what are the
risks here
well the the print that in in even in
wartime we have rules and the key the
key rule in wartime is proportionality
and avoiding any uh any unnecessary
attacks on civilians
uh and and
what we're clearly seeing in ukraine
is no proportionality we're seeing
attacks on civilians we're seeing
attacks on people sleeping in their beds
in their apartments we're seeing attacks
on kindergartens
but overall the overall crime is a crime
of
uh against a nation first of all
mr putin has denied the existence of the
ukrainian nation he's denied the
legitimacy of a people
and it's important to remember that all
every historical record of a genocide
starts with words
it starts with thoughts and words and mr
putin is articulating those thoughts and
words
so
when it when it comes to building up a
case we obviously have to be systematic
in building up a case but we need to
understand
just how bad what russia is doing is
uh and we have to it's hard sometimes to
find the words and
it's not about just sort of trying to be
as creative in in speaking adjectives as
you can
but we need to understand the horror of
what is being inflicted on the ukrainian
people it has no justification
whatsoever
and you can watch the full interview
with canada's ambassador to the un bob
ray tomorrow on the west block right
here on global well ukraine has been
imploring western countries for aid and
it looks like some help is on the way
it's coming in the form of money but
also through international pressure on
russia to end its pursuit of taking over
the country jennifer johnson has more
from washington
as russia unleashes relentless attacks
against ukraine u.s president joe biden
met with his national security team and
made an emergency request to congress to
allocate 6.4 billion dollars for
military and humanitarian aid the former
president of ukraine is pleading for
western allies for help we need
the anti-tech we need anti-aircraft
we just need to increase our defensive
capability to stop the crazy
aggressor in europe
humanitarian aid is desperately needed
too for the ukrainians fleeing their
country mostly women and children they
moved out without nothing even i'm sorry
like no socks no toothbrush
nothing protests announcing russia's
invasion of ukraine have erupted around
the world from the white house to tokyo
many russian citizens are disgusted by
president vladimir putin's brutality we
hate what's just
happening right now in our country
british prime minister boris johnson
says the world hasn't seen anything like
this since the second world war it's a
generation or more since we witnessed
such bloodshed in europe we hoped we
would never have to see such sites again
pressure is building on nato member
turkey to close off passage of russian
warships ukrainians in that country fear
they will never see their loved ones
again i'm calling them every 10 15
minutes i don't know what is happening
there right now
just stand up and do something to
protect our families
seven thousand additional u.s troops are
on their way to europe to help protect
nato allies and join nato's response
force as concerns grow this war could
spread beyond ukraine's borders there's
a historic nature to all this this is
the first time that the alliance has
employed these high readiness forces
international pressure is mounting for
putin to end this unprovoked war but
russian forces are continuing on their
bloody mission as the death toll for
both countries climbs
jennifer johnson global news washington
standing with ukraine the growing chorus
of condemnation across canada and around
the world later
but first learning to live with covet 19
frontline workers look to a future with
the virus
alberta will remove many of its
long-standing covet 19 health measures
on tuesday including indoor mask
requirements premier jason kenney made
that announcement today saying all
evidence suggests the worst of the
pandemic is over along with losing masks
the province is removing all capacity
limits on venues getting rid of all
limits on indoor and outdoor gatherings
and lifting mandatory work from home
requirements
paul
there is no evidence at this point
that to suggest that our transition to
uh
normal is negatively affecting our
health care system
and in fact it appears that overall
transmission in the province continues
to decline
ontario is also set to remove some of
its restrictions next week including
ending its use of the vaccine passport
but its indoor mass mandate will remain
in place
as we enter the third year of the
pandemic there is a lot of discussion
about the need to permanently move on
from restrictions in this country for
the new reality this week jeff semple
explores how that will work on the front
lines of our health care system learning
to live with covid19 has become
something of a controversial catchphrase
used by politicians business owners and
protesters who want to get rid of
pandemic restrictions
but now even some frontline staff here
in this toronto hospital are talking
about the need to find a new way forward
we spent a few days here inside humber
river hospital and met dr leon rivlin
he's the medical director and chief of
the emergency department who's your
surgeon dr rivlin says his most pressing
concern these days isn't covet 19 per se
but rather the fallout from two years of
pandemic lockdown hey there i'm dr
rivlin and staff here are seeing a
significant spike in patients suffering
severe mental and emotional distress
don't give me food we want to help you
the pandemic creates this general sense
of anxiety then when you add
pre-existing disease whether it's
psychosis or depression then it only
amplifies it the question moving forward
is that if there is another wave
perhaps driven by a new variant and
cases climb once again how will we
respond
we'll explore what learning to live with
covid19 could look like including for
those who are most at risk of dying from
the disease
and you can watch jeff's full story
tonight on the new reality at 8pm right
here on global
up next stopping plastic pollution at
the source the push for a united front
to tackle production
you're watching global national
plastic pollution will be front and
center of the united nations environment
assembly starting next week with
negotiations on a treaty to deal with
the problem as redmond shannon reports
the focus won't just be on waste but on
tackling plastic production as well
around 8 billion kilos of plastic waste
enter our oceans every year but that is
only about two percent of the plastic we
make and consume there is mounting
evidence of how broken down
microplastics affect us humans as well
as wildlife plastic is quickly
overwhelming our
food systems its overwhelming uh natural
habitats it is making life hell for
animals it is risking human health
this coming week thousands of delegates
meet in nairobi kenya hoping to do
something about it on a global scale the
fifth united nations environment
assembly will also tackle issues like
biodiversity and chemical pollution but
many eyes will be on plastic progress
with canada co-facilitating those
negotiations primary sticking points
will be around this issue of legally
binding whether or not countries
actually do commit
to these mandatory and specific
obligations and targets the united
nations environment program has done a
number of analyses that have shown that
voluntary commitments are just not going
to address the crisis in the way that we
need them to delegate jane patton says
the ideal outcome will be to set a
mandate for governments to negotiate a
binding treaty by the next meeting in
two years one that tackles plastic
production and consumption as well as
waste management that's really the only
way that we're gonna be able to to
actually curb the harm that comes from
plastics and plastic pollution less than
a tenth of plastic waste in canada is
recycled most goes straight to the
landfill
earlier this month at the one ocean
summit canada joined france the u.s and
others in a pledge to support a legally
binding agreement on that full life
cycle approach to plastics and in
january more than 70 large companies
that make plastics and sell their
products in plastic called for something
similar i think the consumer brands that
have their names on these things when
they wash up on our beaches
are at risk
if they don't do something the canadian
government says it wants to enforce a
ban on six single-use plastic items like
straws cutlery and bags by the end of
this year some municipalities have
already moved ahead with similar
initiatives redmond shannon global news
london next in the battle for public
sentiment the overwhelming show of
support for ukraine here in canada and
around the world
[Music]
as russia's siege on ukraine continues
to escalate so too does global
opposition to the kremlin's actions
protests opposing the russian invasion
are growing not only in cities across
europe but also right here at home
microlay looks at the sentiment of those
taking to the streets
the voices are getting louder angrier
what russia has done
it's more complicated for yuri
novotvorsky he was born in russia and
yes he's angry but he organized this
rally outside the russian consulate in
montreal because he's embarrassed
overcome just full of shame
and and sorrow and horror at what
ukraine has to endure
the war in ukraine is so new it's tough
to nail down what people are feeling
whether it's in new york
or milan the uncertainty is the
condemnation of vladimir putin's actions
but for all the anger there's also an
overriding feeling of helplessness
that's bordering on despair for some
expat ukrainians in calgary desperate
for a way to connect with their homeland
just for some comfort food
yeah we want to
eat some cake and
yeah
drink something try another stuff
the bad stuff is almost impossible to
ignore and with each passing day russia
is finding itself with fewer friends
poland and sweden are refusing to play
russia in soccer's world cup qualifying
matches and more countries are sure to
follow almost everyone it seems is on
team ukraine
the conflict inspired christian boris of
toronto to create a sticker of saint
javelin a twist on the iconic image of
mary magdalene because she's holding a
javelin anti-tank weapon the picture now
a symbol of the conflict as a former
journalist who worked in ukraine he
hoped to raise a few dollars for charity
only days in he's well over a hundred
thousand dollars i think it's just
triggered a court around the world i
mean we see
companies pulling sponsorships
they don't want to be associated with
russia anymore stop the war that cord is
getting louder by the day
at what point will putin hear it
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm sophie louie tonight
we leave you with some iconic landmarks
around the world lit up in blue and
yellow in solidarity with the ukrainian
people thanks for watching i'll be back
here tomorrow evening in the meantime
have a great night
[Music]
you